we were looking at do you remember what
we were looking at it had this acronym
because they don't remember what it
stands for their relation greatest
common devisor you might start with a
pair of numbers right like say 18 and 20
and then the question was well what is
the biggest number that you can divide
hence the divisor into both of those and
not leave any remainders okay so for
example with 18 and 20 do you remember
well how would we break this down how
would we use prime factor trees to help
us can someone maybe give me a prime
factorization of 18 what would you do
first good someone else were to carry on
from Frank's working tour the next thing
heavy ok excellent at this point I can
stop right because they're all 1 2 3
they're all gonna call these numbers at
the end right it's very good so I've got
2 times 3 squared you have enough 20
looks to be like 4 & 5 and then what
happens to this fall
2 & 2 and then 1 2 3 these numbers again
or prime so I'm gonna write it like this
so when you look at that what is the
greatest number they can fit into both
of those 18 and 20 yes it's just gonna
be too - is it right because you can see
here I've got 1 to madina and what a
comment but then I'm kind of stuff
that's all I can do and lowest common
multiples kind of like the other side of
the coin right instead of looking at the
biggest number that fits into vote it's
looking for the smallest number that
both numbers feed into okay I say that
again this is the biggest number that
fits into both but this is the smallest
number that both of them feed into so
let me try to illustrate this okay
million
when I added all of the prime numbers so
in this case 2 3 3 2 2 all those
together yeah the number of the time
yeah when you multiply them I think
everyone yes that's exactly right that's
the whole point of doing a tree so that
we see what multiplies together so let
me talk to you this really briefly and
then you'll see how the idea works
multiple
just being your copy example so it's
easier than understanding a multiple of
any number is what you get when you
multiply that number by another hormone
so multiples come from multiplying right
so 3 times 1 is 3 3 times 2 is 6 3 so
here you go all of these guys are
multiple 3 you can get the multiples of
anything right now
that's what multiples are that's not
difficult I wanna pick that common
multiples so what I say things are in
comment right I want you to look at this
list multiples of 3 and we get this list
the multiples of 5 which multiples do
you see that I want both lists I can see
- yes 13 okay I can see 30 that's on
both lists are there any more yes 15
very good so I've got two multiples that
aren't both lists - multimers that are
common but what I'm looking for is the
lowest comfortable okay so the lowest
common multiple is we can finish the
sentence now before I get to your
question right
the MotorStorm ultimate is the smallest
number that is a multiple of both of the
ones you're interested or maybe you've
got three numbers or four and you want
something that's a multiple of
you're chosen
yes yes that's right so for instance
I've got out well you know I've got the
multiples of three I've got the
multiples of five I could if I wanted to
have the multiples of 15 they look like
this right do you see there 15 is still
on the list right so 15 is a common
multiple of 3 and 5 and 15 okay so if
there's a number and it's not on the
list right for one of them it is the
common tool that's what like that's what
common means it's like a community it
means all of us share it so therefore
they all have to have that one for it to
be a common builder okay now how do we
find the common multiple okay now it
looks like did you notice
15 is connected to 3 and 5 in a really
obvious way what's the relationship
between 3 5 and 15 Selena do you see it
3 times 5
it's Tuesday that's kind of nice and
frequently the lowest common multiple is
you just multiply them together but I
want to give you those in 18 and 30 okay
now these are bigger so a little bit
harder to do it we still can if we try
our strategy before just multiply them
together
18 times 30 it's a bit of a big Mel bar
I think we can do it could we do 18
times 3 18 times 3 18 good seats what's
the next one after that
54 so now if I put the 0 back it's gonna
be 540 so finally reporting
I know it's kind of multiple but is it
the lowest one okay now I'm going to
show you two ways you can do this as a
quick way and a slower way a slow always
easy I'll show you what me see how I
listed out the multiples yup right I
listed for that until I got a number
that was on both lists so let's do this
with 18 and we're 30 we just said some
of the multiples of 18 that's 18 then 36
and 54 what's the next one very good
okay 72 today something bit easier
because if I add 18 2010 will horan I
think we've skipped one right Oh 18 plus
32 is it's just 90 and then after that
he's on a good name
I can't where I got the dot that's a few
of them let's see if I do the multiples
of 30 I get a common multiple so what's
the first wonderful thing buddy how you
doing the next one is 60 haha look I got
one right and I certainly got one a lot
faster than 540 this is huge this is
like six times bigger now
so if is one option yes this is option
one which is list listing more classic
on another pool because all the
multiples will be there then all these
are multiples and we'll just look for
the same one okay but there's a quicker
way yes say that again
yes well I'm gonna show you one more way
maybe if you're always different to mine
they will have three ways okay
the way I'm gonna show you how to do
with them this guy over here these prime
number troops I'm not sure if this is
the direction you're gonna go in okay
I'm eighteen and thirty I actually
already have the number tricks at
eighteen above here I cheated a little
bit can you help me work out what the
number tree 430 is what two numbers
would you like me to put in first - fish
Pinatubo we find how about 15 what I do
with that now Maria three and five very
good okay I'm done now on time I've got
all the primes out one two three
so here are two times three times five
is thirty
okay good so now what we're gonna do how
is this going to help me with this let
me show you remember I said it's all
about common multiples okay so what I'm
gonna do is something similar to what I
did before in that I want to get a
number that has all the visas factors
and all of these espect okay so if you
look if I have a number that has a two
in it and three two threes in fact and
also a five right two times three
squared times five do you see that
whatever that number is I should be able
divide this into it you see it's not all
of these factors in there you see I've
got all the two three and five and it
should be able to do this one as well
I've got all of these factors in my new
red number two and three squared do you
see that so what is this number it's 2
times 3 times 3 is 9 times 9 times 5 is
45 and 2 times one side is uh-huh there
it is right I didn't have to dismiss the
wall out I got kind of lucky that we got
such a short list this is a way of doing
it logically and I might have to list
out hundreds of
this way but option two is not least but
the to use trees and buy trees I mean
planning trees